Speaker 1: We're continuing to follow the
impact of different vaccine requirements,
and some of the most interesting ones to look
at are actually the ones for the military.
We learned from Defense Secretary Lloyd Austin
that the military would be indeed implementing
an actual vaccine mandate.
Speaker 2: It's just you've just got to
Speaker 1: get vaccinated, that it is not
a protocol where you can test out, you got
to be vaccinated.
And we are now starting to see the first discharges
from the military for vaccine refusal.
Now the right is making a big deal out of
this and framing it as unpatriotic.
Joe Biden,
Speaker 2: by making service
Speaker 1: members get vaccinated and losing
service
Speaker 2: members refusing to get
Speaker 1: vaccinated is weakening the military
and is therefore unpatriotic and a socialist
and a Marxist and a communist and right like
follow it along to the whole thing.
Twenty seven people have been discharged.
Speaker 2: Ladies and gentlemen, that is that
is that what
Speaker 1: we know so far.
The Air Force has discharged 27 service members
were refusing the COVID vaccine.
These are the first service members to be
involuntarily discharged for refusing the
vaccine.
Spokesperson for the Air Force said they received
counseling about the vaccines.
They still refused and commanders made the
decision to discharge
Speaker 2: them for refusing
Speaker 1: to comply
Speaker 2: with that requirement,
Speaker 1: considered to be a lawful order.
All 27 of these individuals were with the
Air Force under six years.
There may have been additional reasons for
the discharge, but the COVID vaccine refusal
was
Speaker 2: at least one of those reasons.
Speaker 1: Now they announced this back in
August, so they had August, September, October,
November.
We are now in December.
The Air Force had a deadline of November 2nd,
which was one of the earlier deadlines.
And of course, you don't immediately remove
the people on November 2nd.
You've got to go through a process and that
has now taken place.
Each branch of the military has its own process
for discharge, and they all include We're
going to counsel you about the vaccine.
We're going to educate you about the vaccine.
Then there will be disciplinary action.
You will still have an opportunity to get
vaccinated, and only after that will we start
with the discharges.
And what is fascinating about it is that what
the right says is a horribly authoritarian
thing is no one something that has been in
the military for, what, a hundred years.
Speaker 2: I mean, I don't even know
Speaker 1: when the first military vaccine
requirement came in, but in particular in
the military, there have been so many vaccine
requirements that nobody questioned for so
long.
So no one, if this is authoritarian, where
have you been all this time?
Speaker 2: That's the
Speaker 1: first issue.
Speaker 2: The second is that even the way
Speaker 1: they're handling
Speaker 2: this is eminently
Speaker 1: reasonable.
I'm reminded of the segment we recently did
where Tucker Carlson criticized a CNN host
named Brian Stelter because Brian Stelter
fired his nanny.
He fired his nanny because she wouldn't get
vaccinated to be around his kid.
And when you listen to Brian Stelter, explain
it, he says, Yeah, you know, we really like
the nanny.
And so
Speaker 2: we said, Let's wait
Speaker 1: six months.
She doesn't want the vaccine, but let's wait
six months because she'll see that it's safe
and she'll come to the decision on her own
that she's going to get the vaccine to protect
our kid or kids.
I don't remember how many, and she still didn't
do it.
So it was really tough.
But we did let her go because we want someone
vaccinated around our kid.
Eminently reasonable.
And here with the military, it's we're giving
you months notice that by November 2nd, you've
got to be vaccinated.
You refuse.
We're going to give you counseling.
If you refuse, we're going to give you education.
Speaker 2: We will then just give you write
it
Speaker 1: up and still not discharge you.
Speaker 2: It is endlessly, endlessly
Speaker 1: reasonable for a group that historically
just line up and get vaccinated.
Speaker 2: That's it.
Now the
Speaker 1: other takeaway here
Speaker 2: is that the vaccine
Speaker 1: requirements really work.
Speaker 2: The Pentagon shows
Speaker 1: that about 90 percent of the active
duty forces vaccinated and 74 percent of the
total force, including reserves and the National
Guard, that's significantly more than the
general population.
Of course, it's made up of
Speaker 2: adults, so we've got to make sure
we're
Speaker 1: comparing apples to apples, so
we're going to continue to see what
Speaker 2: happens elsewhere.
So far, just 27 people.
Speaker 1: And so anybody telling you this
is unpatriotic and weakening the military,
it's
Speaker 2: 27
Speaker 1: people from the Air Force Army
deadline is December 15th.
There will be another deadline like the final
final final deadline is the Army National
Guard.
That's not until June of 2022.
So those are the latest numbers as we now
understand them.
Remember, we were told we may lose tens of
thousands of service members here.
So far, it's 27.
We were told we might.
Lose a third of NYPD.
It was what some type was it, 34 people or
something along those lines.
United Airlines, there's going to be no flights.
There's going to be no nothing.
Almost everybody is vaccinated
Speaker 2: now at United
Speaker 1: Airlines, so it's really a twofer
at the end of the day in the sense that you
improve the overall health of your personnel,
you reduce the risk that your personnel are
going to contract COVID and be sick and be
out, et cetera.
But we're also getting rid of some of the
wackiest people.
As we've said before, there's probably if
you imagine a van diagram
Speaker 2: of police
Speaker 1: we don't want because of reasons
other than they don't want the vaccine, either
use of force, not the types of people we want
and police that don't want the vaccine.
There's probably a lot of overlap there.
We're probably getting rid of a bunch of those
bad apples by saying if you won't get vaccinated,
you got to go.
Speaker 2: I would suggest to you
Speaker 1: that it's the exact
Speaker 2: same thing when it comes
Speaker 1: to the military.
If you disagree, let me know.